الان لا تونس للحديث عن ابرز الاحداث لعام
2022 تنضم الينا من تونس زملتنا الجميله
دائما احلام العبدلي احلام يسعد صباحك من
المشاركه المشرفه لتونس في المونديال الى
دخولها العالميه في التنس حدثينا اكثر عن
ابرز احداث تونس
صباح النور على جميلته مقدمات سبحا
العربيه وعلى جميع المشاهدين من هنا من
تونس والشمس لما تظهر بعد لم يكن عمل
الناس
شكرا شكرا نوركم انتم اللي تاغي وانا على
سعيد الشخصي خال بس اقول ملاحظه انه اعتبر
من اجمل الاشياء اللي سالتني في هذه السنه
انه انا انضميت لفريق صلاح العربيه هذا
الفريق الجميل والرائع تونس لم تكن سنه
سهله عليها كبقيه الدول لكن سوف نكون
ايجابيين باعتبار ونحن نبحث عن الاشياء
الايجابيه ونتمنى ان يكون عام جديد مليء
بالايجابيه والفرح والسعاده المونديال
اللي هو ابرز ما تبع هذه السنه ومشاركه
المنتخب الوطني التونسي في المونديال
وفوزه على بطل العالم فرنسا هذا الفوز
الذي جعل المنتخب
الذي كان يراود التونسيين وكان سيخفف
عليهم كما قلنا وات اتى العاب اليوم
والحياه اليوميه كانت سنه تربعت فيها على
قلوب التونسيين وزيره السعاده التونسيه
اونس جابر بطلت التنس التونسيه التي عرفت
صحتي ويمبلدو امجيد انس جابر وكذلك عرف
العالم من هي اول عربيه واول افريقيه وصلت
الى هذه البطولات العالميه اونز جابر التي
اثرت قلوب الملايين وحققت انجازات تاريخيه
واصبحت هنا في تونس وفي دول اخرى اصبحت
قدوه في هذه الرياضه التي تعتبر ربما
الرياضه
كسرت هذه القاعده تلك الفتاه القادمه من
عائله متوسطه ومن المصعد الاجتماعي
التونسي حققت انجازات وانجازات كبيره جدا
ومن هنا نحن نحيي البطل العظيمه
كذلك تونس كانت على موعد مع انجاز اخر مهم
ومهم جدا باعتبار انا التونسيين همم
ينتبهون ويعتنون جدا بالاكل وكذلك هناك
مقاوم اساسي في الاكل التونسي الذي هو
الهريسه او ما يعبر عنه في الشرع بالشطه
الهريسه تدخل العالميه هذه في هذه السنه
اواخر ادي سنه من اوسع ابوابها من خلال
ادراج هذا من التراث العالمي اللامادي
ليونسكو التونسيون متعلقون جدا بهذا
المكون في المطبخ التونسي هو احد ابرز
مكونات الاطباق التونسيه خاصه الاطباق
منها الحاره ونحن نتحدث عن فصل الشتاء
تقريبا يوميا حتى ينسى يتسلحون بهذا
المكون في اطباقهم الشعبيه من اجل مواجهه
هذا الصقيع الذي ينزل علينا الان هو احلام
يا احلام نتمنى ان تتحقق معك كل الاحلام
من تونس احلام عشرين 22 شكرا لك